why I'm pleased to be joined now by a
one of my favorite people that I got to
meet in this business that I do he
joined NFL network back in 2060 Mary J
cannot believe this is the ninth NFL
season we've gotten to hang together not
am a 99 years this is the longest I ever
held a job rich could be honest I'm not
work I'm not worthy this is great to be
on your khmer dan voyage here I'm in the
Rich Eisen show come on this is great
this is good where we wrote guess what
is that marbly be where else would you
rather be than right here right now so
that's the way I feel about it that's
right um so lady earlier we had Jed York
on saying that uh it's categorically
untrue that our balls out at the end of
the season regardless of what's
happening but you know you hear the
reports of from everybody from dion and
everybody else that the locker room is
in shambles in terms of a relationship
with the coach what did you think when
you heard the report that a coach and
week for week four we're right before
week 5 is said to be out no matter what
by the end of the year yeah well you
might hear that with a team that's
losing right but with a team that has a
lot of success in its back pocket for
the last three years and looks like it
will be right there again I found it
surprising um I living up here in the
Bay Area I hear about it a lot okay and
I hear whispers and I and I hear people
that know people that are in the
building and you know and I and I hear
some of those things okay let's just
face it I don't know what the issue is
all i know is that Jim Harbaugh has been
winning there all I know is his next
contract is going to be very hefty
wherever it may be and you know when you
ask a Jed York and I know Jed very well
and he does a great job there by the way
or jon gruden about the raiders job or
any of these things you they answer
questions we all have to answer
questions really in the here and now you
can't predict what's going to
in January you really can't because
between now and then a lot of things can
transpire so the you state what you're
feeling right now like grids will say
I'm thinking about monday night football
I'm not thinking about the Raiders and
gentle say he's our coach and I want to
win a Super Bowl that's the the obvious
answer but that's how they're feeling
right now can things change of course
they can change heck you might sign an
extension for all I know but it's hard
to predict the future you know that
right I know but as you point out and
just in terms of the nuts and bolts of
running an operation there's always a
day to day factor to it and I asked Jed
about the relationship between Trent
bulky and Jim Harbaugh and he called it
professional now I always like joking
with you and we have our fun with you
about you know you and matt millen
clearly as we all know didn't get along
but what is that like for a head coach
to be with a general manager it's not
true well I mean just in terms of just
rich yeah the first like the first
training camp first training camp Matt
Millen and I heck we'd share a bottle
gatorade here during a break you want
this yeah you drink it visit the next
the next year it was like I'll get my
own bottle you get that one you drink
that the next training camp it was like
get your own damn Gator I'm not talking
to you today I mean so sometimes so
sometimes they sure can deteriorate over
time but you have to like Marty
Schottenheimer over there in KR san
diego when he was 14 and two there was
some friction between he and management
and sometimes those things go kitty
Wampus but as you know you know we in
the paparazzi and a lot of fans think
that there's no way that a coach can do
his job effectively or general manager
with that sort of a relationship what
what is that like if Jim Harbaugh and
bulky aren't on the same page all the
time and Harbaugh needs to get ready for
a game how does that work from a head
coach's perspective Steve the only time
that it would well one time that would
be very disruptive and I went through
this in Detroit where the coaches coach
all week and decide who's going to be
active and how you're going to play guys
and you get 46 out of 53
when the general manager comes in and
says I want to see this guy play you
need to have him active he needs to play
not that guy then all of a sudden you
have confrontation because that guy that
the general manager wants who he drafted
may not fit into your plans he may not
be worth suiting up because he doesn't
do anything and so I don't know that
that happens over in San Francisco with
Trent bulky all i know is Trent Baalke
he's got a very very talented roster I
mean maybe the best roster certainly one
of the top two or three in the league
and so they've got to find a way to
coexist deal with it if you don't love
each other but respect each other's
position because it's working right now
it's working now farewell if they were
if they were terrible if they were sub
you know if this was in Dallas and there
ate and ate ate and ate ate and ate
three years in a row right there would
have been some changes a long time ago
what is not the case on what do you
think Rex is going through in New York
right now Steve obviously in your career
you had a Hall of Famer and Steve Young
we also know in Detroit that you had a
quarterback situation that wasn't to the
the greatest of effects with Joey
Harrington and Rex has a guy he's
year-to-year now on his contract
obviously he wants Geno Smith to work
but he does have Michael Vick sitting
there on the bench and he says it's
still Geno Smith what do you what do you
think Rex needs to do moving forward
here Steve yeah I feel bad for Rex rich
because you know a veteran backup
quarterback and a lot of teams have that
backup veteran guy to to be ready or to
mentor the youngster okay and if need be
because of an injury or because you know
they're like jumper cables you know that
living back in the wrist at some point
the jumper cables can you know use them
when you have a dead battery and it's
nothing's happening so you use the
backup is jumper cable whom they get a
spark to try to ignite a fire in with
that team and that's what they probably
were hoping for with Michael Vick in
this game nothing happened he's not he's
not the guy that's going to give him a
spark that's going to lead them to the
playoffs or any of that it they know
that Marty morning wigan Rex know that
so there I don't want to
stuck with Gino because I like Geno I'd
like some of the things that he did as a
rookie I know he's matured as a guy I
mean he understands defense better he's
just not having the success he doesn't
look very good and what did he throw for
27 yards in so it's really really brutal
yeah any was anything he almost looks
like he's lost some confidence and
that's that's the thing you worry about
when you have just a developmental
quarterback you're worried that they
lose confidence because as soon as they
do if they lose confidence and then
themselves I promise you the rest of the
team loses confidence in the team's
ability to win games so Rex is in a
tough spot doesn't get any easier well
there was the Daily News is reporting
that Geno Smith Geno Smith missed a team
meeting the night before Stevie was late
for it let's put it this way he was late
for it and missed it because he got the
time wrong and that the Jets felt that
it was just an honest mistake but there
were other players wondering what what
was up with that how do you handle how
do you handle that have you ever had a
situation like that as a head coach yeah
I had a cup I had guys and you know the
quarterback you don't know there's a lot
of deadlines and times a quarterback no
no III quarterbacks are there early
quarterbacks are the guys that are early
and stay late and that they're you know
really the guys had set the example of
the team and you know you're going to
have an honest mistake once in a while
and if it's from a guy who's never been
late before you know you kind of say all
right you know okay honest mistake don't
worry about it but if there's a history
of him being the last guy in the meeting
room or the last guy to out to practice
then all of a sudden I could see we're a
team would go hey you know what this
guy's really work in the edges I don't
think that's the case with Geno Smith I
think he's one of those early guys so
you know you know I've had I've had some
guys come in late tio I've had a fine
guys at times you know nobody tries to
be late because you know nobody likes to
get a couple three thousand dollars out
of their paycheck
for being late five minutes but that's
that's too bad I didn't hear that story
yeah that's so that that's what's coming
out of the day after and Rec says it's
going to be it's gonna be Gino to go
next week against Denver to holy smokes
I mean it is we got one minute to go
Steve before i got this hard out it is
denver the best team seattle the best
team who's the best team that you've
seen through the first four plus weeks
yeah well you know what you know what if
we had like a bcs kind of committee yes
or the playoffs with Condoleezza Rice
and Archie Manning and again all those
with the I think I think we would have
four teams from the West yeah four teams
from the West that would be in the
playoffs it would be Denver like you
mentioned it would be Seattle certainly
it would be the 49ers will we wait till
they get everybody back that's a scary
team and it would be the San Diego
Chargers all these four teams yes right
now I'm sorry about that East Coasters
these teams in the West right now are
dynamite and they might be the best
teams and Denver looks like it's it's
going to be a scary team yeah well I
think San Diego it's time we start
talking about about it is a Super Bowl
contender and we'll talk about that on
our next segment on the Rich Eisen show
thanks much appreciate you firing out
muj camp floors